[Music]
the movie has come a long way from
wanting to be the fairest of them all
revolution is a coming-of-age story if
we've ever seen one watch until again to
see the villainous princess transform
into her awesome and super fashionable
self Evie was born and raised on the
Isle of the lost her mother the Evil
Queen taught her that there was nothing
more important than being the fairest of
them all so she grew up under the notion
that beauty came before personality
despite the odds Evie was born with a
golden heart and a handful of virtuous
talents the blueberry princess is a
gifted chemist and an exceptional
fashion designer in fact she's the
genius who makes outfits for many of the
V K's in her hometown some would even go
as far as calling her a fashion icon in
the making unlike many villains Evie's
not the one to lash out for no reason so
she's often regarded as one of the most
pleasant to be Kay's to be around
although she was raised to be cruel
unjust and wicked Eve each owes to
forego her mother's expectations but
that didn't stop her from being a little
wicked to say the least for as long as
she could remember Evie secretly longed
for a different life you know the one
that involved castles and princes and
happily ever afters so in Maleficent
announced that she had been chosen
alongside mal J and Carlos to attend our
don prep she was over the moon however
she knew better than to broadcast her
excitement so she kept her feelings to
herself but she wouldn't be doing that
for too long without Evie I our favorite
VK group just wouldn't be the same
she's giddy spontaneous and optimistic
so she can easily put a smile on her
friends faces whenever their morals are
low but believe it or not there are some
things that Evie isn't good at and
mainly that staying true to herself
Evie's charisma isn't hard to miss still
she's a crowd pleaser who doesn't
usually speak her mind this character
flaw was clearly showcased when Doug
brought mal and Evie to their dorm room
in the scene we see an awestruck Evie
gazing at her new living quarters
however when now
expresses her hatred for it Evi agrees
with her despite really liking it
[Music]
learning how to embrace her true self
plays a big hand in Evie's evolution
being raised by the Evil Queen ensured
that Evie would grow up to be shallow
and entitled but her bubble was burst
when she met Audrey for the first time
Audrey was quick to dismiss Evie's
princess status reminding her that her
mother had been stripped of her titles
this revolution worried Eevee for more
reasons than one a popular one being
that she desperately wanted to marry a
charming prince and live in a castle as
time went on though Evie soon began to
realize that just because someone looks
good on the surface doesn't mean that
they aren't rotten to the core
anyone who knows Evie knows that beauty
is everything to her with this in mind
we weren't surprised to see how obsessed
she was with her looks throughout the
first descendants film Evie's dark blue
locks are her trademark and her favorite
accessory is her crown the princesses
outfits stand out amongst the rest of
her crew but that's to be expected we
mean why would she give her best outfits
to other people she's got a reputation
to protect after all in descendants Evie
is seen wearing a jacket poncho hybrid
it's made out of dark blue leather and
is fashioned with a belt she also wears
a pair of black grafitti tights and a
matching skirt she looks like a total
rock star Evie's also wearing her famous
red locket and a pair of high-heeled
boots she's sporting her mother's colors
and it's not hard to see that Evie is
the fairest of them all but that doesn't
stop her from worrying about her status
every now and then before leaving to art
on prep her mother gives her what's left
of her magic mirror its last remaining
powers can only point her in the
direction of what she seeks but since
its mal Evie Carlos and Jays mission to
steal the fairy godmothers wand it'll do
just fine
much like her personality Evie style
evolves as she starts embracing who she
is deep down just wait until you see how
different she looks in descendants to
one of Evie's brilliant powers is being
able to brew potions like there's no
tomorrow she's an expert in chemistry
and is highly intelligent despite
pretending not to be
Evie learns a lot during
first year at our don prep but mainly
she learns that she doesn't either
Prince to make her dreams come true at
first all Evie wants is to date Prince
Charming and become the princess she's
meant to be but she soon realizes that
chad charming is a full-time doofus and
part-time bully
Chad tries to get Evie expelled by
revealing her magic mirror to the
teacher
luckily doug comes to the rescue and
stops her from getting the boot it's
here that we learned that Evie isn't the
pushover we thought she was
despite her dream she hangs Chad out to
dry and reveals just how much
self-respect she's got in the bag
she stops pursuing Chad and begins
falling for Doug who's been nothing but
sweet and supportive sure he might not
be a prince but he's her knight in
shining armor during this time he also
realizes that she wants to be good so
she starts speaking up for herself and
vibe me into a different frequency by
the end of the first film Evie has
already transformed into a strong and
independent villain but that's nothing
compared to how much she evolves from
descendants to
[Music]
it's hard to recognize Eevee from
descendants - this is due to her acting
like a completely different person where
she used to be shy reserved and vain
she's now outspoken and in tune with who
she is on the inside her boyfriend Doug
has a lot to do with her transformation
but in the end all he had to do was give
her a push in the right direction Evy
starts her fashion line Evie's four
hearts in descendants - and she uses her
newest vocation to help others look and
feel as good on the outside as they do
on the inside Evie has to become her own
person and she's put her mother's
lessons on the back burner she's truly
embraced life at auradon prep and
doesn't miss the way things used to be
unlike mal Evie isn't compelled to use
magic to her advantage instead she makes
her dreams come true on her own so with
her new personality in place she starts
to scold mal for using her mother's
spell book and she encourages her to
donate it to the museum it belongs in
the museum along with my mirror Evie's
finally who and where she wants to be
unfortunately trouble comes knocking and
changes the course of her
picture-perfect year many issues our own
Evie's way throughout the second
descendants phone however some could
argue that they weren't of her own
making Evie and mal are super close
friends so anything that happens to her
directly affects Evie as well despite
trying to encourage her besties to stop
using spells mouths magical endeavors
eventually backfired sending her running
to the Isle of the Lost
when Evie Jay and Carlos found out that
their pal was missing they were hot on
her trail
Evie dropped everything she was doing to
go help her friend putting herself at
risk in the process that doesn't sound
like something a villain would do now
does it at this point
Evie isn't a happy relationship with
Doug and she wants the same for mal and
Ben so she accompanies him to the Isle
of the Lost with hopes of bringing mal
back to auradon unfortunately things
don't go as planned and Ben gets
kidnapped coincidentally this events had
to occur to make mal realize that she
truly loves Ben and wants to live in
auradon Evie put everything on the line
to save her friends cutting herself free
from her roots in the process although
evie used to be selfish it's pretty
obvious that she's completely changed
her ways come descendants to move over
leather poncho and make way for Evie's
newest outfit the Evil Queen's daughter
looks even more stunning in descendants
too than she did in the original her
wavy locks have been straightened out
and a gorgeous braid frames her face in
case you were wondering this is what a
happy and confident villain looks like
Evie still rocking the dark blue look
but she's added some individuality to
her outfit her red heart patching gloves
reflect her incredible new personality
they tell us that the princess now wears
her heart on her sleeve
she hasn't ditched the leather look just
yet but she clearly has a newfound love
for be dazzling everything she sees
studs and jewels lie in her leather
jacket dress making her look like
royalty it's obvious that it is not the
same girl we were introduced to in the
previous descendants film she's evolved
so much in so little time and she's not
afraid to show it with Doug's help she's
been selling her designs to the people
of auradon and she's living her version
of a fairy tale it's hard to believe
that her d3 outfit is even better than
the one we're looking at now but it
totally is so keep watching to see her
latest look when we are first introduced
to Evie she's quick to side with MAO no
matter what she says but that's not the
Evie we've come face-to-face with in
descendants to the new and improved Evie
speaks her mind and doesn't let her
bestfriend influence her decisions
Evie's right where she's meant to be but
she can't stop thinking about someone
who's stuck where she doesn't belong
Evie reunites with her old friend dizzy
while rescuing Ben from the Isle of the
Lost
the young hairdresser designer is the
very opposite of a villain Dizzy's
biggest wish is to follow in Evie's
footsteps so being the selfless and
considerate person she's grown to become
Evie convinces Ben to invite dizzy to
our don prep at this point it's clear
that helping others makes Evie happy so
in other words she's become a total hero
after returning to art on prep Evie is
met by a frazzle Doug he's obviously
been freaking out over the fact that
Evie didn't come home the night before
he accuses her of seeing someone else to
which she replies don't
Doug's anxieties immediately dissolve
proving just how solid their
relationship is by the end of
descendants to Evie's transformation has
come full circle
yet somehow her evolution is far from
over Eason and spans feared that the
franchise is coming to a close after its
second installment but Disney Channel
has announced that descendants three is
in production actor Sophia Carson is
reprising her role as Evie and we can't
wait to see what she has in store for us
they paved the path for us by releasing
the short movie trailer under the sea
and fans were quick to point out that
Evie was nowhere to be seen so they were
definitely relieved to see her putting
up her sword in the official d3 trailer
the three cool is set to air in 2019
Evie's already such an accomplished
character but it's hard to imagine how
her transformation will continue with
this in mind
Sophia shared which he hopes will happen
to Eve you with her fans according to
the actress Evie is the nicest of the
four BK's so she'd love to get to know
her wicked side fans are holding out on
the possibility that Evie will turn evil
in the three kool but that's a story for
another day
Evie is seen fighting her way through
the movie trailer so we can expect to
see her ferocious side at the least Evie
is no stranger when it comes to powers
and abilities however many of us were
left wondering if she possessed any
magics of her own while she had access
to a magic mirror and an all-powerful
mother in the past
Evie isn't one to play around with
spells of any kind it's old news that
Evie has a knack for chemistry and
science so by default she knows how to
make a good potion nevertheless it looks
like Evie didn't inherit her mother's
sorcery which is a good thing depending
on where you're standing all in all it
looks like Evie's talents end and begin
with the fashion industry when I look at
you all I can think of this she's
creative nifty and resourceful so that's
a plus if we take the animated short
series descendants wicked world into
account though we find out that Evie
isn't magic list after all in the
series Eevee possesses the ability to
cast spells alongside mal so perhaps we
will see their combined abilities save
the day in descendants three when it
comes to powers Evie still has a long
way to go so we're curious to find out
if she'll evolve in this department as
well
descendants fans lost it when the Disney
Channel revealed Evie's new look and
well that's probably because it's
downright stunning Evie has always been
the vk2 watch when it comes to style and
let's just say that her d3 look doesn't
disappoint
Evie style has always been heavy on the
bloom and light on the red but this time
around the princess is embracing some
new colors Evie is wearing a cropped
leather jacket that is equal parts white
blue red and black she's wearing a
pleated skirt black tights and combat
boots - Evie seems to be in warrior mode
which is fitting given the trailers
contents once again her hair has changed
drastically but not in a bad way
Evie's hair is now the bluest it's ever
been and the color does wonders to her
complexion she truly looks like the
fairest of them all her hair's longer
than ever and slightly curled at the
tips and to top it all off she's wearing
a ruby encrusted tiara from the looks of
it Evie is embracing a new side of
herself and leaving the all blue look in
the past what do you guys think about
this transformation sound off in the
comments below all in all it's easy to
see why Evie is a fan favorite the
princess went from being a shallow and
self-absorbed villain to a sweet and
selfless hero in a short amount of time
deep down Evie's always known who she's
wanted to be but her mother's lessons
led her to believe that being rotten to
the core was the only way to go once she
was given the chance to create her own
identity
she chose to follow her heart instead of
her mother's orders for the first time
in her life she realized that good
people were worth protecting
so she faced the Evil Queen and many
other BK's to do what was right Evie's
transformation is beautiful on the
inside and out she set aside her vanity
and created a business that helped
others look their best she realized that
there was no such thing as the perfect
Prince but there was such a thing as the
perfect boyfriend
great in there so are you I bet I can
get him a on the next test without the
mirror dougie came to her defense in her
time of need
making her want to do the same for
others Evie's transformation defies all
odds making it even more remarkable so
which one of her looks was your favorite
let us know in the comments below and
that's a wrap
give this video a big thumbs up if
you're excited to watch descendants 3
and don't forget to subscribe to the
things for more videos like this one
thanks for watching and see you next
time
[Music]